negli episodi precedenti di residenti
c'è un tesoro
cominciano prendere rai non è morto
procede liri o capitolo ucciso
l'implosione insorto
c'è chi bello adesso no lui non c'è
mi piace un giocatore lo sa lui no
no lui no ragazzi ora avrei preferito di
quegli altri 2 miliardi di zombie
indicando che tranne lui no lui no
ragazzi sto fuori le colonne numeri non
ci posso fare affari non ce la faccio
con logori un ragazzo pro porca [ __ ]
così presso la porta si è chiusa tra
l'altro questa carica porca [ __ ] va
bene mi mi spiegate una roba via in
questi due metri quadri come faccio a
schivarlo
ma la butto via forse lo posso fare così
e basta come lo schifo allo zio 3
madonna che schiaffo c'è un buio
moderato mehdi sarà la bava maschiata
quanto quanto grosso tratte non si fa
niente
picchia misto lasciato lanciagranate in
bocca non gliene frega niente qualcuno
gliene frega nulla sa bene come prima è
finito
hai finito mai chiamato gli altri a
raccolta
nel doppio io ho sparato a lui è come
fatti come lo schifo domanda semplice
come cazzo
io non posso schivarlo perché ci sono
troppi pochi metri quadri che vi
distanziano da questo tizio non so se
avete il tipo di sparo l'altro si farà
questo sarà quello live e morto a posto
allora aspetta aspetta facciamo una cosa
la magnum non l'ho ancora usata ma
proviamoci mai in faccia proprio ok
e bello che scuote la testa non gliene
frega nulla la magnum è fortissima e
ragga fan al danno passetto
[Musica]
ma chi è yes
io ve l'ho detto che la mani ma era
incredibile martello cristallizza io ve
l'ho detto che la maniera incredibile ve
l'ho detto io ve lo dissi e ciò ancora
tre colpi e gli off dio risparmiati
tutti bomba artigianale
guarda che non usati tanti e ragazzi non
usati veramente tanti di colpi giuro
cioè non avete idea perché la magnum una
sola vale come dieci colpi di doppietta
c'è quindi per farvi un proiettile solo
quindi per farvi capire quanta roba
usato era veramente questo qua non
potevi farmi niente mamma mia
proprio lui cristallo grande non è che
c'era qualcos'altro quel giro hanno
visto che sembra quando ci sono i
cristalli per aumentare la potenza delle
armi
l'atm i potenziali suoi under così le
slot decripta ragazzi tutto sto casino
per arrivare a prendere un flacone di
merda eccolo tra l'altro dobbiamo fare
tipo saw l'enigmista prendo appena lo
prendo va bene ho completato il puzzle
di mia figlia
che succede se la madre miranda quindi
madre miranda appena alla prima compaq
quando la combatteremo e insperate anche
il nostro gigante fai un fatto ancora
uno sforzo e sarà tutto pro tra l'altro
il tizio gigante l'ha creato lui la
credo l in cambio in cambio cosa
innanzitutto vieni qui metti flaconi
nell'altare e il resto lo capirei da
solo ai presto il secondo me i ragazzi
vuole che io faccia fuori madre miranda
in modo tale che poi riprendere il
controllo non lo so
la sto buttando lì però vuole che io la
dall'isola per questo piatto di
guglielmo grazie ragazze questo piatto è
finalmente il piatto di guglielmo lo
aspettavo dall'inizio del gioco che
cazzo ci giova
era questo era come prima era di sotto
12 anni per capire dov'era qualcosa
adesso ho trovato è ben visto peccato
non posso farmi correre le mani
mickey è fortissima la ragazza dei
ragazzi allora andiamo li devo tornare
nel punto dove c'erano i fondatori e
mettere i quattro flaconi andiamo a
mettersi i flaconcini le scuole amico
dove aicardi quali qua di qua non questo
era questo un centrale sega anno quando
messi a minchia ok ma io gli sto andando
a dall'altra parte va bene amici sono i
ricordi da bambini sia stato
poverina da una cerchiata adulti la
testa no niente ma pensavamo di essere
un ricordo a flacone ok va bene
perfetto and the last and wine is this
one vediamo luca intanto sta morendo mah
vabbè tanto lo fa sempre
e quindi calice dei giganti vabbè è
quindi aperta la strada perfetto senza
carta govern adisca di skyrim trova
isenberg subito jean 2 euro proprio
tanto ciò solo una magnum pronta per
sparargli in faccia ma che pirla
qualcosa di giganti e questo non ci ho
pensato proprio ok
e adesso
minchia kraken ma no si è sollevato un
ponte va bene
mi sembra un po eccessivo tutto per
calice prova bene vita nel calice di
pietra a mi ricordava un me la ricordavo
diverso a questa dati bari potter e il
calice di fuoco ma fa niente
sono tutti gli elementi ci sarà anche
calice d'acqua che non so quale sia
notare che non so contare con le dita
quindi per arrivare alla fabbrica di
heisenberg che doveva raccogliere i
pezzi nyan win
già benvenuto a lei non pensavo a
preferisco un fitto donna in ruolo ma in
america sei sopravvissuto è infatti si
era quello che ti avevano dormire in
confronto a run tutorial questo non è un
tool mirante diga contrappone tranquillo
non è una trappola sangue ocean drive a
la vedo grigia e secondo me però fate
che non ci sono proiettili in giro
quindi potrebbe dire la verità non vedo
niente hanno messo polvere da sparo di
qua non si sa non capisco neanche bene
dove sto andando lui crea gli abomini
l'aveva detto nell'altro ci aveva detto
all'inizio interagisci
se potevi farlo anche in più o meno
horror scontro ma mi vedi che la verità
russo che senso lei aveva tanto ci
vorranno un miliardo ricordiamo è farmi
fuori come gli altri
così potrai salvare rose giusto
tecnicamente la poesia figlia però senti
tu non hai capito niente
cazzo sto parlando chimica è chi è che
ha acceso una moto ai nostri cazzo bravo
bravo mi sia piaciuto perdonami ma
comoda ma e io non ci starei seduto
vicino a quella bocca ascolta i tanti
hanno preso in giro mi sono seduto
davvero ma di che stai parlando
pensi che sia un gioco ho detto siediti
da le norme stronza con il culo cross me
la ricordo la matta con la bambola lo
scherzo della natura
il pezzo sei il mio di madre è un test
per vedere se sei degno di entrare nella
famiglia di mira non voglio far parte
della famiglia di mira ma nemmeno io ma
eccoci qui e io sono il prossimo giusto
mi fai fuori prendi il mio posto beh col
cazzo me ne sbatto dei tuoi problemi
personali
io rivoglio solo mia fede eh sì anch'io
lo sai quanto è potente quella bambina
anche miranda ne ha paura
fanno di nuovo stronza e giuro che ma
chi cacchio è sto tizio che fa così
questa è la motosega cos'è io e te vita
insieme possiamo salvare rosa e poi
usarla per schiacciare miranda come un
verme
mia figlia non è un'arma [ __ ]
ultima chance non vuoi sapere che c'è lì
sotto fidati
correrò il rischio
vabbè ciò le palle quadrate almeno
almeno ci ha avuto le palle quadrate è
piaciuto a questo dialogo
io l'avrei fatto che soltanto nel dubbio
salviamo mia figlia e poi al massimo
miranda di cazzo mi frega ma scusa
andava bene io l'avrei accettato orca
[ __ ]
buongiorno e un motore quello bravo
spara al motore orc ethan sei un po un
[ __ ] però vabbè verso praga
cosa devo fare qui vi giuro non lo so
non ho idea
scappo sicuramente non lo fossero fuori
con la pistola vicolo cieco
ecco non affittati ficcati incazzo
quando mi può raggiungere ragazzi dai
toni io l'avrei fatto ragazza che ha mai
fatto salva mia figlia comunque chi se
ne frega se poi ammassiamo miranda con
la figlia va bene ma che cos'è non era
un brutto piano secondo me scatti
arrugginiti scat elogi nieri distensione
bouquet chiesto casi asta che sta
scendendo pure lui veloce allora veloce
zio veloce che arrivano city è fatta
questo posto ne andai minchia la shin
cazze final fantasy fuggire la fabbrica
di sicuro non volevo rimanere quel tizio
è durato poco
sto detto l'ho detto apposta regalo
detto apposta perché adesso in 3 2 1
non facciamo anche in tempo ad aprire la
porta guarda c'è duca che cazzo fai qua
è una macchina per professore uno stampo
per usarla una macchina serve uno
standard che sia chiaro non c'è corrente
beh ma ci manca solo quello guarda chi
ci fosse questo c'è un tizio giorno
style è che qua al casino se ti muovi il
pizzo giudizio orribile sul bomber ciao
mi chiamo lorenzo piacere e il tuo
spazzolino questo vedo che lei bing i
denti non è che se li lava tantissimo
proprio questo che fece stampo vero
rilievo che l'ho trovato adesso tornano
indietro il suo questo si sveglia io
corro io corro io corro va bene io
corrono proprio ok
arrivederci river ciò lo stampo stampa
per un'idea questa roba
grazie
rilievo del cavallo mi sarà utile ma che
cosa te ne fai scusa quando devo ficca
ho girato due ore non ho capito la
logica resto cosa era qua di bianco la
visione della corrente amici ti prego
datemi una mano
qualcuno sa dove il generatore i core
costarono il cavallo pakistan perché la
chiave del cavallo ancora non ce l'ho
quella quella la vedo grigia però scelto
di non dello zero penso fosse un tizio
svizzeri magnum minchia treno trovate
giorno più felice la mia vita ma sti
tizi qua nel mentre non vengono
tranciati scusa della domanda stupida
fammi vedere come pure lo zombie così
per favore era esattamente non si fa
niente lui sa ok mischia se non moriva
così ragazzino andavo o che grazie
ragazzi avete la mia giornata è a posto
questo va bene è andata parecchio bene
per adesso raga non su quanto duri il
pezzo della fabbrica ma devo
assolutamente diverso la corrente che
senza quello andiamo adesso una parte
scartiamo finiti
ok esco ma tira tira tira nice
la donna siamo dovremo prima perche ci
sia no non è non siamo per altri no cosa
che c'è qua dietro madonna che ansia non
l'avevo visto ma adesso si staccano si
staccano cento per cento non si è
staccato sblocca la porta lo sbloccata
vediamo ok siamo quasi alla calma calma
calma calma che siamo qua
ok qua c'è un muro da spaccare lo posso
far fuori tranquillamente ciò in cui ero
con la bomba
a parte il fatto che non puoi averne più
di cinque di moda gli ex fi che non cela
dietro l'inizio di fucile è qualcosa di
grosso parte meccanica mi sa che proprio
c'era un pezzo che mi serviva generatore
di riserva vai manca una ruota dentata
l'ho appena presa ma ce ne vuole
un'altra quante carte di nove devo
trovare giro madonna già è difficile e
poi qualcosa che c'è un'altra parte
mcenroe talebana stampo per ruota
dentata va bene ok
adesso ci sia adesso sia psi si
svegliano tutti quanti non si è
svegliato quando ci ripasso di nuovo si
svegliano tutti ma sai che non ho capito
porca [ __ ] queste scenico a guarderà
qua la porta questo era il generatore
nicchia 60 anni adesso ti svegliamo
tutti ricreazione ok
secondo me non è stato il massimo
delusione da merda merda
questi sono scene sono scemi quanti ne
hanno svegliati così di matti
accostamento tutti noi a essere suoi
figli sia rinchiusi in questa città è
già un casino
di qui ho bisogno di più potente tanto è
morto
se vuoi il mio fucile zio è l'unica roba
che mi viene in mente perché sennò non
saprei come questi sono i frutti del mio
potere dataset reported il trucco noi
deboli
ecco si chiama il mondo non aventi mai
promotori più tardi madonna che botta ok
ok questo che ho fatto malissimo subito
ok questo è morto e mori
alle spalle o lo scollo ucciso lo stop
trick shot ambiente che allora mais un
bel cuore meccanico una domanda lecita
se tutti i nemici devono essere così io
come faccio ad andare avanti perché è
più complicato nel senso che io non
posso andare avanti dalla pistola
stanzialmente questo che sta dicendo
quindi datevi una regolata la gente che
sta qua infatti mi dà un sogno disegni
la precisione se ci fate caso non c'è
non c'è un fucile norma non ci sono
preti normali bada solo a prendere il
corso che quando non poteva aprire
perché non c'è la corrente adesso si può
aprire questa corrente me la ricordo io
la rosa eccoci qua perché c'è qualcosa
qua dentro sicuramente dico qualcosa di
a parte due tizi appesi al muro miri
mandello vince chissà cosa ci qua dentro
sala operatoria munizioni stordenti
questi si alzano dopo dico quindi già
aprendo le robe fuori perché possono poi
non le posso riprendere munizioni di
precisione va bene mi faccio solo un
attimo di è perché sicuramente adesso si
muovono e quindi non mi posso più
tornare a prendere
non c'è da anni bisogno è uscito uno dal
libro
raga ho finito quasi muniti delle
missioni del del cecchino e non è per
niente una buona notizia visto che mi
bastano solo per farne fuori un altro
sostanzialmente non me non mi bastano
per per nient'altro
quindi speriamo che non ce ne siano più
perché sono ciò nel deretano doppiamente
cos'è che c'è qua dentro a rio medico e
di aria un aereo né di rivitalizzazione
di tutto sto casino per una canna lunga
amiche cosa
cos'è la volt viene a un aumento aumento
il danno della magnum ma assolutamente
ragazzo ho fatto la lascio parlare
ragazzi che sta parla dell'operazione ho
mangiato di un minuto fa qui e ci siamo
ragazzi abbiamo raggiunto anche sto
punto che non solo ci siamo dietro non
ho idea ma almeno polvere da sparo ma
c'è gente sicuro perché cosa per sparare
ma chi ha un altro però attenzione
perché facesse qualcosa elettrico di
succede per tutti
fatto niente
a questo ma non al punto debole merda ok
mi piace ma cela dietro
nove ragazzi ci manca nuovo romanzo già
difficile
a volte dai fermo resta fermo dai sempre
fermo
a un metro gioca tutto ok ok e mori mi
piace il fucile a pompa adesso che il
titolo ricordi non sono bastati manco
per 1 2
non è morto e attenzione
non so cazzi futuri o minchia non ci
posso credere prezioso addirittura
questo c'è qualcosa dietro
madonna non ho più colpi ragazzi e non
fatemi scherzi perché non c'è più niente
non mi fate combattere contro questi non
c'è più nulla
dovrei tornare dal duca oltre che andare
avanti qua però
giovanni michiara non può che non lo
vedevo vai con lui proprio non least lui
non mi sparo niente quindi la casuale in
questa è la fine l'episodio di oggi il
residence iva ci vediamo domani con un
altro episodio cose e mi piace anche ai
social minuto perché se non solo ci si
chiede come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo
bella ragazzi
[Musica]